You understand the mosaic of culture about how
movies sort of affect everything.
Has it always been like that for you?
Yeah.
I mean, most of my life, I've gotten a lot of my
markers from movies and behavioral things, you
know, whether it was recognizing that no one can
slap me across the face, you know, like Sidney
said, do you know what?
Did you just hit me?
Did you really just hit me across my face?
See, that comes from there?
That's where I got that from.
Because I knew as soon as Sidney turned around
and looked at that man, that that was not
acceptable.
It was not acceptable.
So movies have often given me insight as to how
other people may be feeling about things.
Of course, we're talking about "In The Heat of the Night"
What I registered in that moment, too, was the
other actor that look of delight on his face when
Sidney slapped him back.
I mean, that was a thrill to me, because for the
first time, I felt like Sidney wasn't in the world as a
black person by himself.
For me, Sidney was instinctual.
He was an instinctual actor.
And when I watched him, all right, that's the only
time, exactly as you're saying, that it was like,
Okay, you're not the only one here.
You see the guy behind you sees, and he just
his face said everything. Said good...
Somebody need to slap your behind back, you
know, cause, you know, and I have to say, I love all
those actors in that scene because they could not
have been an easy one to shoot.
You brought up Sidney and, you know, I gotta ask
you what it was like, if you remember seeing him
win the Oscar. What was your memory is of that?
Yes, I remember my mother and my brother, and I
jumping up and down, just jumping up and down.
It's like, Wow! Our guy won! The winner is Sidney Poitier
And it's because we love Sidney.
It's just because we loved the actor.
And then later on, I sort of understood the
weight of what he had done.  Because it is a long
journey to this moment.
I am naturally indebted to countless numbers of people
But I didn't understand it at the time.
I just knew we love Sidney.